hey guys it's max with max tech and in
front of me I have the brand-new 2018
15-inch MacBook Pro with Vega 20
graphics I did a video already looking
at performance benchmarks some thermal
seeing if it throttled on my other
channel which I'll link to down in the
video description I'll also have a link
to this exact model that I'm testing but
in that video a lot of people are asking
about gaming performance so much so that
I installed Windows 10 I downloaded some
games on here we're gonna be looking at
for at night the brand new battlefield 5
which I haven't even played in black ops
4 and we're gonna see how this thing
performs in gaming so right now I'm
running utage in heaven I ran this on
Mac OS I want to see if there's any
differences when we're running on
Windows if we have some performance
improvements with the operating system
now I know and I hope that nobody's
buying this machine just for gaming it's
very expensive but if you're buying it
for video editing with Final Cut 3d
design doing other kind of work but you
want to do some gaming on the side would
be great if this thing performed well I
tested some of the previous models and
even though you could play on medium to
low graphics it really wasn't great and
in my benchmarking video the thing that
surprised me the most was the Unigine
Heaven performance and how much of a
difference we got compared to the
previous best graphics card the 560 X so
the results are in and yes under Windows
10 the performance of this graphics card
for gaming is much better we're looking
at a thousand two hundred and thirty
five score compared to nine hundred and
sixty seven that I got under Mac OS
Mohave and the FPS went from thirty
eight point four all the way up to forty
nine so that is a noticeable improvement
so if you have games that are
cross-platform I would suggest you run
the under Windows 10 using bootcamp so
now let's go ahead and close this down
so let's start out with black ops 4 and
I know some of you guys aren't you
asking about the Gaming Mouse that I
have dongle DUP - the MacBook Pro here
I'll go ahead and leave a link to my
favorite gaming mouse download in the
description so I'm in the graphics
settings it sets a native resolution
here which is crazy you know you're
looking at 2.8 K or so I'm gonna go down
to 1920 by 1200 slightly higher than
1080p texture quality high texture
filtering high medium effects model
quality high static reflection quality
hi it's choosing some high settings on
here alright so I changed the settings
to mostly medium with some of the
effects
turned on motion blur turned off and the
internet here is kind of sucky so I'm
seeing a little bit of lag frame rates
are running at about 50 right now 48 52
I saw some go into the 60s but as far as
any sort of framerate drops and lag from
that it's actually looking a quite
smooth still running about 45 during
these shoots here hands are kicked up
and they're quite loud so we're gonna
get about 50 frames per second now and
it seems like we're running between 45
to 65 frames per second and if I
remember right this is the map that had
the most difficulty with frame rate wise
because of all the snow and the
particles in our budget gaming PC build
so I've been playing for about five
minutes here on this other map yeah so I
have everything kind of medium settings
anti-aliasing different effects some
effects that you just turn on are just
turned on and in this game I'm basically
above 60 all the time sorry now I'm at
63 some spots I'm like at 75 with medium
settings and effects turned on so you
can turn a few more things down but man
we're staying about right there and that
firefight dropped down to 56 was the
lowest actually this is great I mean if
you want to play some game some black
ops after done video editing and doing
whatever else you do now you have a
pretty decent gaming laptop and in
Unigine heaven just on the Mac side up
the graphics were about 85 percent
faster compared to the five sixty so
definitely a good improvement if you do
any sorts of gaming the Vega 20 is
definitely worth it alright so we have
another map here
I changed the settings I lowered some of
the effects to like medium that I had
lower the anti-aliasing and resolution
from 1920 by 1200 to 1080p and then I
raised the texture quality to very high
so the maximum
and we runnin around here 90 FPS 95 FPS
like I said that snow map is very
difficult to use if there's ever been a
Mac look that you can play new games at
decent settings this is it - is too many
of them
so I am thoroughly impressed now let's
jump into battlefield 5 I actually
haven't played battlefield 5 yet say let
me get into the game now oh man so let's
see what the default settings are i mean
visually oh my goodness this looks
really good compared to black ops the
lighting looks nice gosh
oh man oh man get down I don't know
about you guys but I am playing a
brand-spanking-new game that is gorgeous
like the lighting is here is incredible
on a MacBook Pro without any issues I
don't know what the frame rates are I
don't have a counter on here but it
feels nice and smooth it seems like the
settings are set really high because
this is just beautiful to do the chanc
cinematics the night scenes look at I
like the lighting in here do you're done
with video editing and whatever and then
BM dude look how beautiful this looks
you're right that was a trailer they
would sell a lot more it was running
that beginning cinematics full you know
2.8 2.9 K basically so I'm playing here
at 1080p I have film grain vignetting
lens distortion on chromatic aberrations
on the blur effects are on in the
graphics settings it's set to auto max
fidelity and the textures and suffer are
on medium here I'm at 64 frames per
second right now 62 frames per second
65 I'd like to kick the textures up a
little bit more but that screen tearing
is going on meaning we're running faster
than we need to
so I'm customizing the settings I set
texture quality to high most everything
else is on medium in the anti-aliasing I
dropped a little bit lower oh my
goodness
oh my goodness so right there are 60 fps
it is extremely consistent I am very
surprised and we're running out 58 to 60
to 62 frames per second let's at the
texture quality to ultra now our
graphics are still at 60 57 right there
dip down to 57 I was getting shot at
staying at 60 and we got smoke going on
here that typically makes it harder
we're at 60 still
I don't know if it's clocking higher
when I have more demanding things or
what's going on but this framerate is
insanely consistent I've never seen
frame rates that are this consistent
maybe this game is just super well
optimized so to finish off I'm gonna
switch it to 1920 by 1200 lighting
quality let's say that's ultra effects
quality high processing let's turn that
up alright so we upped all those
graphics we're in a map with all this
snow here we have all these particles
that are flying around which is
typically very hard for games and right
there when I died as a 58 fps
I don't know what's going on my vertical
sink is turned off sometimes it's going
above 60 so I guess we'll have to turn
up the graphics even more let's just set
everything to high I guess and keep the
lighting and textures on Ultra alright
so finally we have some dipping frame
rates here we're at 52 50 53 I mean the
frame rates are so consistent I think if
we weren't on a map with a bunch of snow
particles we'd probably be close to 60
here yeah 47 right there when I died me
and this game has really really good
optimization I'm so impressed so I can
officially say that if you want to play
battlefield 5 man this is impressive
better than black ops 4 which is already
good if you set your graphics settings
everything too high add even higher than
1080p you're not gonna have any issues
and the game looks gorgeous so now it's
time for the game that has the worst
graphics and probably the worst
optimization as well so let's go in the
settings set everything on high we're
gonna keep that massive full resolution
they're flying around 57 58 55 60 so
we're at 59 58 60 frames per second
where are you oh so I'll be honest this
is basically the first time I'm playing
for nighttime still level one here I'm
not into the whole dying and waiting so
long to join into another game and what
if it's just this graphics card that is
so consistent with frame rates then and
I've watched some footage online but the
graphics always look pretty bad and I
wonder if most people play at 1080p here
we're probably running double or maybe
close to triple of 1080p with this
display and look
quite good framerate wise were right
around 60 frames per second sometimes
dips into like the mid 50s
yeah shotgun okay
wait I killed a tree I thought he was
just hiding behind there or something
nope there's a guy guys I don't know
what I'm doing he's gonna kill me oh
it's that guy again switch to my shotgun
no no no stop stop building stuff
give me my shotgun where's my shotgun
what's he died no I think that's about
it for fortnight obviously I don't
really know what I'm doing but with the
highest resolution everything on high
settings here one takedown from ultra
we're staying right in the mid 50s 260
almost like there's some kind of a vsync
turned on the fans don't seem as loud as
with black ops 4 in battlefield 5 but in
this in the game settings we have vsync
turned off so I don't know if there's
something else that it could be
affecting it may be aimed II settings
and there 55:58 whoa okay that was cool
so I think it's safe to say that if you
want a place on for tonight on your
MacBook Pro with Vega 20 graphics you're
not gonna have any issues we're here at
high settings maxing out the resolution
2880 by 1800 and the frame rates are
great if you want to lower it down
you're gonna be able to get even higher
frame rates so overall I'm very
impressed with a graphics card that they
put in this machine I wish i
I do wish that these graphics cards were
available at lunch because I know a lot
of you guys bought the previous 5 60 X
version and now you have an option that
is much more powerful especially for
gaming I will be doing a lot more tests
on my other channel like I said check
out the link in the video description
where I did a bunch of benchmarking
performance and thermal testing you guys
definitely wanna check out that video
make sure you guys subscribe enables
notifications so you guys don't miss out
on future videos overall quite
impressive
and this is the first MacBook Pro that
can actually do a decent job at gaming
with these new modern titles thank you
guys for watching this been max with max
tech and I'll see you in the next video